[Music]
hello thanks everybody for for coming
along to what is otherwise they a cloud
conference to hear a little bit about
Android do you all hear me okay first of
all great cool so yet today we're going
to learn a little bit about Android
enterprise and what's coming up my name
is Ben Breen I actually lead Android
Enterprise engineering and we're we're
actually based out of London Android is
actually built between two locations we
have a the largest team here in Mountain
View but we also have a team of around
300 people in in London as well so so
this session we're going to see some of
the new things that are coming up in the
next release of Android and I you know I
have to say this disclaimer that a some
of the things you see here today they
may not make it into the release I think
they will but there's always a chance
that they that they don't so so yeah
this is this is why Android this is why
Enterprise is important to us in 2019
Android is forecast to ship over 280
million smartphones intended for
business use and according to research
from IDC in 2018 81% of personally owned
smartphones a ship for businesses will
be running Android and 67% of company
owned smartphones will be running
Android as well so i'm not i'm not
showing these numbers simply for the
vanity metric so I'm just showing you
them to show you how important
Enterprise is to to Android and why we
are investing so much time and efforts
into our b2b initiatives
so there's been a sustained investments
in enterprise across multiple releases
of of Android in lollipop we introduced
something called the work profile for
BYOD which allows users to completely
separate work and personal in their
phones in marshmallow we we introduced
the concept of corporate-owned
single-use devices and runtime
permissions in nugget so as we say in
the UK or new Gertz as you say here we
introduced the work app security
challenge so you know getting into
certain apps you might require extra
authentication such as a fingerprint or
pin code and we also introduced the
digital well-being aspects for work
profile allowing you to turn on and off
the work aspect of your phone and in
Orio we added zero touch enrollment
which means that as soon as you take
your phone out of the box it Emeril's
itself into your organization without
the need for any contact with IT and in
PI we introduced multi-user improvements
as ephemeral users users that only use
the device occasionally or or as a
one-off and further improvements to work
profile and we'll take a look here at
what we're going to introduce in Android
Q as well now most of Android Q will be
revealed at Google i/o which is another
conference that happens intagram woman's
time and so definitely follow that as
well because you'll get all sorts of
announcements around some of the
enterprise and also non enterprise
aspects of Android key
so the enterprise team focus itself on
three types of user IT admins ensuring
that they can manage easily manage and
secure Android devices and minimize the
number of support tickets that come
through line of business so specialists
in in in in-house applications or
specialist hardware employees ensuring
that employees are able to control their
privacy and digital well-being and and
also we're ensuring that Android is the
most productive platform for employees
to use
so
Android also provides multiple layers of
security so not only is it a robust
platform built from the ground up to be
uncompromising ly secure Android also
supports dedicated security hardware
such that you might find in pixel and
many other phones Android has management
API is to allow EMM s to enforce
policies and give IT visibility into the
security posture of the device and also
there is Google Play protect which
allows always-on app analysis and takes
automatic actions should anything
untoward be happening on the device so
if we look at security through the the
eyes of Gartner's mobile OS security
reports google android actually leads
the way with security
it's the moat it's most feature complete
in terms of the built-in security and
also corporate manage security on here
light blue means weak and that looming
strong and we pride ourselves in being
secure and on my team we have a number
of enterprise security specialists
complementing the platform wide security
specialists we have as well
so I think like I think one of the big
misconceptions about Android is that
it's not a secure platform in fact
Android security is very best and
effective offering enterprise-grade
protections and controls to ensure
devices secure and in fact in android 8
there are more areas which are rated
stronger than any other competition
according to Gardner's reports in 2017
so that includes app updates
secure browsing authentication methods
just what device swipe and corporate
white workplace isolation and app
monitoring and control and actually the
2019 reports issue out shortly and so
we'll see where Android 9 features on
that as well
so Android is also easy to deploy we
offer a wide range of methods to set up
devices QR codes and then an NFC bumper
really popular now particularly on
dedicated devices and in Android reo we
introduced zero touch enrollments which
I mentioned before and it's now very
popular as well and it's something you
can speak to your mobile carrier about
and they can set this up for you and
then other device management side we
provide multiple modes for IT admins to
choose from
for personally enabled devices we offer
something called the work profile
charlie introduced on the next slide so
these devices are typically referred to
as BYOD work profile offers a unique
approach that protects work apps and
data whilst respecting the privacy of
users and for company owned devices we
offer three options we one of them is
personally enabled devices so we offer
we offer a work profile for company
devices as well which offers a uses of
separate segments where they can not
only operate in a secure way but also
have their privacy respected as well we
also have work managed mode and for
single-use devices we also have cos you
mode where you can lock the device to
certain apps for certain use cases
so this is work profile this is this is
one of my favorite features of Android
and you know the way that I often
explain this is it's like having two
phones in one phone on the left you've
got personal on the right you've got
work and actually you can simply turn
off your work phone when it's time not
to be working so there's a switch at the
bottom and it's also an OS level at an
OS enforce security boundary between the
two which means that IT can manage and
do whatever they want in the work
profile but at the same time whatever
happens in the personal profile is
private to the user and you can still
ask those device why questions like you
know is there anything untoward
happening on the device and take action
accordingly without compromising the
privacy of the user so so it eliminates
those scenarios where you people might
be carrying around two phones and also
we've seen one of the main reasons for
the lack of adoption on BYOD as being
people very conscious about their own
their own privacy so this is a way where
people can maintain that privacy on a
single phone
and so
so some of the benefits of work profile
it offers a great work-life balance it
allows people to turn off work when it's
time not to be working but it also
allows IT to make sure that the device
is it's secure as well and they can
manage the the work side of the phone
another feature that we have in Android
is managed Google Play so this is a part
of the Play Store which you can curate
and control as as IT admins and you can
also silently push out apps as well and
if you have a work profile then on the
work profile side your when you go to
the Play Store your lap you'll go to the
corporate part of the Google Play and if
you're in a personal profile then you'll
access personal Google Play and you can
also remotely configure applications
such as setting proxy servers for Chrome
and all of that type of stuff another
thing we've been working on really hard
in 2018 is making sure that IT and users
have greater consistency across Android
so one of the call-outs that we've had
when we speak to IT and users is the
devices can be quite different from an
enterprise context depending on which
device you pick and it could be quite
quite confusing sometimes to to know
which device to choose to buy
and so with all of these device options
we decided to try to help standardize
around some best practices in the
industry and so we launched Android
enterprise recommended for mobile phones
and this was really about helping IT
admins to make informed selection
decisions around the phones that they
are buying so they know if a phone is
Android enterprise recommended then it
supports a very rich set of features for
for the enterprise and it also has a
high degree of standardization when it
comes to things like UI's secondly we
also wanted to make sure that all of
these devices supports its zero touch
enrollments and we also wanted to make
sure that all a device AR devices have
regular and frequent security patches
applied to them as well so by choosing
an Android and enterprise recommended
device you can be confident that the
device is going to work well in your
enterprise and consistently so so far on
the knowledge worker side of devices we
have 1200 1200 EMS on-boarded with this
program and over 60 devices and four
rugged devices we have 800 EMS and 15
devices
and so our main focus in 2018 was
launching this program and our focus now
is the rate raising awareness of this
program and making sure that ITR aware
and have a large set of devices with
consistent capabilities to choose from
and this year we've also launched a ER
for EMS
so Annie mmm sometimes it's referred
sometimes people refer to them as uem so
these are your your mobile lines or air
watches or Google and endpoint
management the things used to control
and monitor your your fleets and devices
AR for EMS ensure that EMS support
Android in the best possible way and
when we launch new features for Android
they are available sooner for you to use
by your EMM
so we have a number of EMS already on
board so this program as you can see
here and we'll be expanding the AER
program to include mobile carriers and
system integrators later this year
the other focus for us is line of
business so so the line of business what
we're thinking about here we're talking
about specialist devices and specialist
apps often built in-house knew your
business and often when we think about
Android enterprise we think about more
traditional use cases for smartphones
and tablets these devices are driving
end-user productivity and I use for
customer service back-office and support
but where Android really shines is for
all the other device types and use cases
we see single-use devices deployed in in
the field inset with service technicians
customers are using Android and rugged
for rugged tablets in harsh environments
and in retail and hospitality customers
are deploying Android devices as kiosks
or points of sale systems and digital
signage and we're starting to see
exciting use cases for AR and VR here as
well
and because of this device diversity
we're able to serve the needs of a wide
range of industries from field service
to retail hospitality to healthcare and
because Android is an open platform we
at Google don't need to be experts in
each of these industries our OEM
partners are able to develop highly
specialized devices to meet these needs
and the other exciting part of the
device diversity is we now have mobile
devices reaching far more people than
before so turning frontline workers into
you know foreign line workers warehouse
workers field service technicians in all
into knowledge workers
and we also have a robust platform for
building experiences so we provide a
large variety of the leading leading
developer tools to create line of
business applications so you have
Android studio and obviously you can
build in Kotla and Java C++ and other
languages one of the one of the things
that I've been learning recently is
flutter and that so I I tend to work on
iOS so I don't I don't usually use high
level programming languages but I think
flutter is really interesting because
it's it's for the first time I think one
of the the toolkits that allow you to
genuinely write code once and have it
run with the native experience across
multiple OS is so you can you can use
flutter to create ios and android apps
with a single code base and we're using
a lot internally inside google now and
you may have seen we also announced
hummingbird recently which is an
extension so flutter I think it's in
alpha but it also allows those same apps
to run on the web as well so it's yeah
prior to this like back in my long
history I do stuff in QT for
cross-platform developments and then I
did some stuff in samurai and they all
had their you know pros and cons but
I've been really excited about flutter
and you have a Android as well we have
machine learning tensorflow lights and
ml kit so on device ml and you have
Google Play for distribution and
third-party development tools such as s
AP and Salesforce
and of course developers can integrate
with assistance on device or cloud
machine learning we have a few use cases
in Google where we do learning on device
but we've also got some use cases where
we do the learning in the cloud we'll
then apply the knowledge treats of the
device and use the mo software on device
there AR and VR is augmented reality
virtual reality is becoming increasingly
important with a lot of business
customers and Android things as well and
of course Android apps are natively
supported on Chrome OS as well so
thinking about employees well of course
you've got your familiar productivity
apps and the employer can only see what
happens on on these badged apps the ones
with the briefcase in in work profile if
you have a work profile enabled which
means that if you are not using a badge
tap you know that you have the privacy
that you expect and of course you've got
turn off work mode on your work profile
which I introduced earlier
so so what's next work well what can we
expect in queue from an enterprise
perspective
well key themes improved end-user
experience more IT control and enhanced
security tools
so corporate-owned devices can can now
be enrolled through zero touch QR code
or NFC directly into work profile during
setup wizard
so that was previously not possible now
you can if you have work profile enabled
then you can enroll users directly into
work profile and this this is not for
BYOD devices this is for corporate owned
devices again giving you giving your
users that that separation between work
and personal
another another request that we had was
well on a device with a work impersonal
profile if I'm trying to schedule
something I need to I need to see where
I have a free slot and I need to see
both my calendars together and so that's
something that you couldn't do before
now we've introduced an API which if
your IT admin allows some some calendar
information can flow between the two
profiles and can help you find where you
have a free slot in your calendar and if
you want to edit something in your work
calendar from your personal profile you
can do that what actually happens is the
the work version of the app comes to the
foreground it looks like you're within
the same app you're actually not it's
actually switching between the two
calendar apps from the personals of the
work and allowing you to edit the
details of any calendar item so it keeps
it secure another another common or
popular request was separate input
methods for work impersonal apps so
obviously IT have a strong interest to
make sure that there aren't things like
key loggers installed or apps which
might be sending information in spun to
another server whatever people are
typing in well now you can say for my
personal apps I want to use this
keyboard while still maintaining IT
controls for the for the work apps as
well so supports having two different
input methods
and also more RIT control going forward
you'll be able to install updates
manually from a file this allows users
to test rollouts staged them or stagger
them and prevent bad bandwidth or or
scheduling issues so you can actually
make sure that phones are getting
updated when people are typically
offline or asleep and that builds on
what we added in Android name which is
the ability to freeze device updates for
up to 90 days we've also improved Wi-Fi
provisioning so IT admins can now
configure a certificate based Wi-Fi
networks during setup and put those
credentials in the QR code or NFC tag
and this simplifies setup and makes
makes connections makes connectivity
automatic now I think I anticipate
question on you know is it is it safe to
to put those credentials into the QR
code I think it's going to be using the
easy connect standard if you're familiar
with that but so I think things security
shouldn't be a concern but let's see
when the final version comes out
so we also support device difficut it
was only a short video anyway it's not
it's not a huge problem so we also
support device difficut s-- through
google identities so now what you can do
is connect to a public Wi-Fi network
provision the device so put in your
credentials and it will automatically
download the certificates and then
connect you to the Wi-Fi network
requiring the certificate so also
simplifying setup as well
enhance security so there's a concept of
DPC's you might not be familiar with it
unless you're sort of heavily into it
EMM s but a DPC is the app that EMM s
like your you know your mobile iron or
your your air work or your engine
installs answer your device to then
manage the device now often that the EMM
is not an expert in say analyzing
network activity and working out whether
something untoward is happening there
and so what what you can now do is
delegate that to another another app
that can do that analysis for you and
the same for certificate installation
and installation of apps
another common feature which was locking
deployments of work profile was the
ability for a user to install an app
from an unknown source on their personal
profile now as an administrator you will
be able to lock the user from installing
apps from unknown sources on their
personal profile as well so you can
guarantee that everything has come from
the Play Store and is and it's got both
the server-side and client-side
protection so it's a feature you can
you'll be able to turn on as an
administrator another another thing
we've added is a suite a screen lock
quality check so we had this API before
called da device admin and that's now
been deprecated one of the things that
did was allow allow you to or allow an
app with privileges to change the pin on
a device and that was useful for EMS and
things to make sure that a strong pin
was in place but it was also a door for
things like ransomware which could you
know just put a new password on your
device and ask me for money so the way
we've got around that is to you can now
interrogate the OS to say does does the
password meet certain criterias of
criteria for strong and if it doesn't
you can prompt the user to take action
or you can take action yourself to erase
the device or do whatever else you want
we've also we're also be adding private
DNS supports so organizations can
require DNS over TLS to avoid leaking
URL queries and to keep all those
internal host names secrets and secure
[Music]
you